si vous voulez mon avis sur Palmade il a
rien à [__] en prison pour moi il doit
la décision qui avait été prise par le
le juge était la meilleure décision
possible c'était de le mettre sous
bracelet électronique dans un hôpital
psychiatrique spécialisé pour les
addictions et on le soignait et il était
il était enfermé parce que avec un
bracelet vous pouvez pas sortir de
l'endroit qui vous a été assigné sinon
ça ça sonne immédiatement et on vient
vous chercher j'en sais quelque chose
voilà alors
c'est vrai que ça fait énormément réagir
pour vous il dit Pierre Palmade n'a rien
à faire en prison Raymond
qui va en prison alors personne va en
prison alors si si quelqu'un qui se
drogue et qui prend le volant en sachant
qu'il est drogué qu'il est sous
médicaments tue des gens donc c'est pour
moi c'est pas homicide involontaire
c'est homicide volontaire si lui il va
pas en prison personne va en prison mais
en même personne en présence moi c'est
toujours facile quand ça vous arrive pas
de dire non il faut pas qu'il aille en
prison parce que ça arrive pas aux gens
tu vois c'est toujours facile c'est
toujours facile de dire bah moi si un
cambrioleur qui vient je le tue pas
parce que ça fait pas arrivé bah ouais
si on viole ma fille bah non bah
monsieur je veux pas que tu es je veux
pas qu'il aille en prison parce que ça
t'es pas arrivé à chaque fois on a des
débats comme ça tu vois et souvent j'ai
dit il dit ça il dit non moi je le fais
pas et hier il a dit pour les transports
je prends souvent les transports c'est
vrai que c'est chiant bah oui bah c'est
chiant parce que là il était concerné
moi si moi je veux bien que Palma dit il
avait pas en prison moi je suis je veux
surtout que tout ce que comme Palmade
qui font des choses comme ça souvent moi
je vais vous raconter un truc je
vous avez un gars que je connaissais
arrêté au feu rouge 18 ans l'état arrête
au four je voulais tourner à gauche une
voiture est arrivée en face à 100 km/h
cannabis alcool la personne est décédée
la personne est morte on a dit il n'ira
pas en prison ce qu'il a servi pour des
causes humanitaires etc etc moi j'aurais
voulu que ce mec là il aille en prison
et pas qu'ils sortent libre parce qu'il
faut penser aux familles il faut penser
au drame qui se passe au drame qui
quitte au drame que ça fait ça détruit
des familles si moi qui moi pour moi il
doit aller en prison voilà et que
Monsieur Balkany dis il a rien à faire
en prison alors qui on est en prison
voilà maintenant ou après ce procès
parce que
d'abord
parler d'un truc là on parle est-ce
qu'il doit aller en prison ou pas pour
vous en prison après un procès je vais
même plus loin je vais même plus loin là
on est en train d'essayer de vendre une
salade de dire et comme il est malade il
va rester il peut rester un an en
hôpital psychiatrique c'est-à-dire que
si après il prend un an de prison on va
lui on va dire bah ça y est il a été en
prison et non il sera resté à l'hôpital
moi ce que je dis c'est que si il doit
aller en prison il faut qu'il aille en
prison après français si on décide qu'il
doit en prison il doit en prison il y en
a marre des gens qui font n'importe quoi
et qui mettent la vie des gens pendant
enfin moi ça fait trois jours je
regardais l'émission j'étais pas là ça
fait trois jours que là pour moi c'était
limite très bon c'est quand tout d'un
coup l'opinion fait la juridiction il
est assez dur on est au Balto depuis 3
jours ça marche pas comme ça déjà un
jour tu es une grosse bêtise tu as dit
il est pas malade malade c'est cancer la
grippe machin si tous les psychiatres te
diront que addictologie neurologie
psychiatrie s'il y a des centres c'est
que c'est des maladies un alcoolique
c'est un malade la dépressif c'est un
malade pourtant il y a pas de cancer à
drogué c'est un malade donc déjà tu es
une première bêtise et deuxième bêtise
tous les avocats te disent que ça y est
on est aux États-Unis c'est la vox
populi on l'a mis en prison parce que
justement ça prend de telles proportions
avec des gens comme toi qui vont battre
la taille là que du coup les juges ont
fait ça pour éviter que les gens
descendent dans la rue la vérité c'est
que tous les avocats te disent que la
détention provisoire c'est lorsqu'il y a
crime pour le moment il n'y a pas crime
il ne devrait pas y être et tu sais quoi
ils ont même sorti une espèce de
jurisprudence qui est que éventuellement
une amie en prison et je te le dis son
avocat va le casser va sortir il
jurisprudence qui est que éventuellement
ce serait pour pas qu'il recommence donc
on va nous expliquer qu'un type qui a
fait un AVC qui fait 12 kg et qui aura a
brasser électronique chez lui va prendre
de la coke sa bagnole sachant que son
bracelet sonne au bout de 32 secondes sa
bagnole et repartir rien ne tient là
c'est la Banque Populaire c'est la
première fois que les juges ont cédé à
l'opinion et c'est très important ce qui
se passe parce que pour l'instant vous
ne savez rien sur rien et ils ont cédé
le pignon ce type tout horreur qu'il a
faite pour le moment tous les avocats de
comment tous tous les magistrats vous
disent il n'a rien à faire en prison et
son avocat va faire casser ça en
quelques semaines
exactement
alors arrête d'être au bateau
c'est pas j'ai un pote qui a la justice
c'est des règles il y a un code pénal un
code produit à pénale et c'est pas un
pote qui était au feu rouge et j'ai mis
je file que j'ai connu c'est pas ça la
justice
moi je suis dans magistrat de la
pédophilie je suis dans les mots mais
t'en sais rien pour le moment laissez
parler toi tu me dis gnagnagna moi je
vais dire gnagnagna il a commencé à
prendre de la coque il avait 20 ans ça
fait 34 ans qu'il se drogue 34 ans qui
prend sa voiture en passant à travers
les gouttes 34 ans qui se passe rien et
toi tu dises en bourré tu as
conduis-nous la différence entre Palma
d'étoiles c'est que toi tu as eu de la
chance tu as eu de la chance mon pote
t'as pas eu d'accident genre assumé
derrière il faut assumer il faut faire
une lettre alors tu tombes pas dessus tu
expliques pendant 10 ans tu as cours du
bourré mec en train d'essayer de
contourner les lois pour pas qu'il aille
en prison il faut assumer
pas les lois au contraire moi je suis
pas gnagnagna le bateau on me demande ce
que j'en pense je dis que quelqu'un
pendant 34 ans qui est passé à travers
l'écoute malade ou pas malade peu
importe tu as eu la chance qu'il a eu
plein de fois de se relever plein de
fois on lui a tendu la main plein de
fois on lui a dit tiens il y a des gens
on leur tente pas la main comme ça
il y a des gens à qui on donne pas de
seconde chance il y a des gens qui
payent cash tout de suite et toi tu veux
qu'on donne des deux efforts que tu dis
des accidents de la route les gens ne
sont pas en détention bon point de vue
moi je garde mon point de vue du bateau
pour moi il a tué un enfant et un enfant
de 6 ans qui a encore à l'hôpital on
sait pas si longtemps que c'est faculté
et on a dit qu'il y aura des effets
derrière peut-être tu auras des
conséquences je souhaite que ça t'arrive
jamais et je vous souhaite une bêtises
tu as dit il y a deux il y a deux
justices et ben justement il y a deux
justices et pour lui la mauvaise justice
elle est pour lui parce qu'il est connu
s'il était pas connu il serait pas en
détention aujourd'hui pas du tout
entièrement d'accord alors arrête de
raconter des conneries sexy vol qu'il
aille en prison il faut aller en prison
il y a ta justice toi que tu veux que
tout le monde peut faire ce qu'il veut
tout le monde peut prendre des voitures
c'est un code moi j'ai la justice du
bateau je veux pas que ça arrive encore
et ben c'est pas le balcon je sais pas
alors moi je suis entièrement du côté de
Raymond excusez-moi Mathieu mais si il
doit aller de ce côté-là il y a aussi
non mais il y a aussi des raisons
objectives excusez-moi le risque de
réitération il existait vraiment avec un
électronique avec un bracelet
électronique également
et également là où il était à Villejuif
les magistrats ont pensé qu'il n'y avait
pas assez de surveillance c'est un des
critères qu'il pouvait s'enfuir et
éventuellement reprendre de la coca avec
un bracelet voiture et reposer un fil
répond avec un bracelet vous n'êtes pas
magistrats avec un bracelet mais c'est
pas vous qui avez le le compte rendu de
ce que les magistrats ont pensé les
magistrats on dit qu'il y en avait un
risque sévère donc je suis tout à fait
d'accord il faut entre guillemets
neutraliser Pierre Palmade et en prison
il ne pourra plus faire de mal à
personne donc c'est une jurisprudence
c'est la première fois fois qu'on met en
détention provisoire quelqu'un qui n'a
pas commis de crimes maître du
commandant
ce qu'on va continuer le sujet et on va
parler de des fantasmes non voilà non à
78 %
avec les propos donc oui voilà voilà
ça c'est le Balto non mais depuis trois
jours tu dis des conneries
pas besoin c'est pas parce que je dis
pas comme toi que je dis des conneries
c'est mes conneries à moi c'est pas une
opinion la justice c'est des codes
d'accord un jour il y a quelqu'un qui
rentrera c'est un proche de chez toi
qu'il poignardera qu'il volera la télé
et il n'aura pas en prison parce qu'il a
cambriolé il faut pas qu'il aille en
prison un jour il y a quelqu'un de ta
famille
les choses il faut que les gens soient
responsables il faut que tu dises que
quand tu as pris de la cam et quand tu
es drogué quand tu es alcoolisé que tu
es dans ta maison il faut pas conduire
prends un chauffeur assied-toi derrière
prends c'est toi derrière il a les
moyens de s'asseoir derrière qui
s'assoit derrière pourquoi il a pris le
volant merci pourquoi il a tué des gens